Welcome to human emotion.
Um,
today we're going to continue our discussion about this really mysterious and
exciting kind of emotion that really seems to be about ourselves.
So here we're gonna to have a journey into this idea of what our emotions that
are about the self.
What are these things we call self conscious emotions.
And today we'll focus in particular,
as you can see here on pride and embarrassment.
So I,
you'll think about,
and I'll have you think a little bit later about examples in your own lives and
where you can remember feeling really proud or perhaps tragically embarrassed.
And what was it that was about the self here?
In what way did our self awareness play a role in these emotions?
And what kinds of social consequences did it have for us to feel proud or to
feel embarrassed?
So again,
what we're going to do here,
this is part of a two module series where today we're going to focus on pride
and embarrassment.
And after that we'll turn our attention to shame and guilt.
So again,
let's start here today by delving into the nature of exactly what is pride and
what is embarrassment.
So I want to start first with pride.
So we think of pride.
What I'd like to have you do is to draw an experience from your own daily life.
So I want you to take a moment and take out a piece of paper and a pen and think
about a time that you remember feeling particularly proud.
Perhaps you,
you know,
um,
won an award or gained admission to college or did something that you felt
really good about.
So identify one moment in your life that really stood out to you where you
remember feeling proud.
And while you're thinking about this,
what I'd like you to do is to think a bit about sort of what were the contexts
in which you felt proud.
What kind of thoughts were going through your mind as you were feeling proud?
How did you feel about your relationship within your immediate social circle and
what consequences did it have for you at the end?
After feeling proud?
What,
what changed in your social circle?
So take a moment,
just a couple minutes,
you can pause this video,
write down your own sort of memoir of a time you remember feeling proud and when
you're done you can pick up with the video and we'll go through some of the
scientific discoveries about what pride really is and what it looks like and why
we have it in the first place.
Okay.
So we talked in the last module about briefly the characteristics of pride that
it's elicited by a personal sense of achievement or accomplishment.
That the behavior is really focused on advertising.
You're elevated status,
sort of showing other people you've done something important.
And as a result,
um,
the idea or consequence that can often emerge as sort of gaining respect within
your social hierarchy or maybe sort of gaining some sort of elevated social
status.
So these are the characteristics of pride.
Now when we think about pride,
we want to ask ourselves,
what does it look like?
So these are a couple images we started out with in the last lecture where we
looked at this,
you know,
human body builder as well as a chimpanzee.
And if we look at other examples,
um,
of people who have won,
you know,
metals or achieve different kinds of accomplishments,
we start to see some similarities across these pictures.
And you have to start to ask yourself,
you know,
well,
what does pride look like?
Um,
if it doesn't have a certain sort of signature on the face,
doesn't seem to have some unique displays of its own.
Right?
So if you look at these pictures here,
what is it that you're noticing all three have in common,
very different circumstances,
very different people or species in the case of the chimpanzee.
But yet there seems to be some common themes across these three pictures.
So this was a question that Dr Jessica Tracy first began to examine when she
wanted to understand this question of what does pride look like?
Does it have a unique signature?
And so in her research,
she systematically documented the nature of what pride looks like.
And here as you can see,
she identified three core features of the pride display.
So the first component of what pride looks like is that you see the head and
neck tilted slightly back as this woman in the photos demonstrating.
And the function of this is to sort of look above other people,
to let them know that you've done something important.
The second is the sense of making the self look a bigger than life.
So you're trying to expand your posture,
sort of increase your sense of body mass.
So you're drawing your shoulders back.
Um,
and this is supposed to signal a sense of social dominance and also draw
attention to the self.
And then finally what you see is a very slight smile.
Um,
so this is supposed to indicate that you're not just being dominant in some sort
of aggressive way,
but you want to draw attention to others.
You want to signal dominance,
but in a way that is prosocial by showing the slight smile,
you want to let people know that you're friendly,
that you're still part of their group,
and that you want to be socially cohesive.
So it's an interesting balance between showing someone you know that you've done
something important and you're sort of elevating yourself.
But while still maintaining that subtle smile that lets them know you're still
friendly and you still want to be part of their group,
you still want to be their friend.
So these are kind of the three kind of core features of what pride looks like.
Um,
Dr Jessica,
Tracy wanted to ask this question though is when we document these features of
what pride looks like,
can we actually recognize pride and other people?
So you might remember the pictures we showed you earlier of the bodybuilder,
the chimpanzee,
you know,
the Olympic athletes and as well as the pictures here that used in her own
research where she tried to ask this question of are we able to recognize pride?
So here in her study she had participants,
you photos just like these and she was asked,
um,
you know,
in an open ended way,
simply when people saw these pictures,
they were supposed to,
um,
you know,
provide an answer to the question of which emotion is being expressed in this
photo.
Right?
So they could just answer this in an open ended format.
And what she found is that 89% said that these were demonstrations of pride
should they showed this remarkably high recognition rate of 89% of people for
this open ended question would note that they recognize that the display of
pride in these photos,
um,
and this was consistent across different genders.
As you can see here,
these are the actual photo she used in her own research.
Um,
and if you want to see a bit more about some of the work that she's done,
um,
I'm going to show you a brief clip here.
It lasts about two minutes.
Um,
that has an interview with Doctor Jess Tracy showing not only are people able to
recognize pride,
but that this seems to be something that we may almost be born with.
Um,
their studies of individuals who have been blind from birth.
And nonetheless,
when they,
when a particular accomplishment or they feel the sense of achievement,
they will show this same universally recognized display of pride.
So it seems in some ways that pride,
even though it's more cognitively complex in the realm of self conscious
emotions,
and even though it emerges later in life,
seems to be something that we may all be built with and that we can all
recognize in an instant.
So I want you to take a look at this video right now
and now we turn to the thrill of victory and the way we celebrate it,
we're seeing it over and over again in Beijing Olympic medal winners erupting in
those displays of pride and joy.
But it turns out that victory dance has science behind it as explored by ABC's
John Berman
Middle Swimmer Michael Films in 1997
spelling bee champ,
Rebecca Sealfon have in common,
who knows it?
Phelps can spell or Sealfon can swim,
but they both can celebrate their victory.
Dances the scene eerily similar orange stretch,
chest out,
screaming with joy.
Tiger Woods did it at the u s open,
Rady Chast Dayne when she won the World Cup in 1999
coincidence did failed sealfon wards and Chaz Dean all have the same celebration
teacher.
No,
they were born with it.
A study out this week in the proceedings of the National Academy of Sciences
suggest these types of celebrations are inherited traits.
In the course of evolutionary history.
It's been adaptive for humans to respond to successes in this way.
They studied blind judo athletes from the 2004 Paralympics people who never had
sight,
who could not have learned this dance by watching others and found they
celebrated the same way as people with sight.
What's more,
some our relatives in the primate world look like Dave won a game or two.
It's a quick signal telling others,
Hey,
look at me.
I'm successful.
These displays of dominance from chimps and gorillas are very similar to the
displays of pride you see in humans.
Couldn't the Red Sox,
Johnathan Papelbon winning the world series pass for a jumping chimp?
Of course not everything can be explained this way.
Chimps don't wear shirts and of course there are few other mammals that can
home off icky shuffle.
I hope from seeing this video,
you have a sense of just how prevalent pride is and how you know across
different people.
Both people who have been congenitally congenitally blind and those who haven't
across humans and even non human primates,
we seem to have this display of pride that as doctor Jess Tracy says says,
Hey,
look at me.
I'm important.
I've done something accomplishable and that you should pay attention to me.
So that those were some insights into the nature of pride.
Now one of the questions that Dr Jess Tracy and her colleague Richard Robbins
wanted to know though is his pride universal across cultures.
So here they traveled to a country in west Africa.
Um,
this was a pre industrialized society with subsistence farmers and individuals
who were literate and had very minimal education and wanting to know even in
this very nonwestern I society would they be able to recognize pride displays,
especially given that we know that they're more cognitively complex.
So these are actual images from Doctor Jess Tracy's travels to this country.
I'm studying the Burkina Faso people and um,
some of the field work they did,
trying to take the methods from the lab studies you've seen earlier and
translate them to this particular group.
So here what they did is it's pretty much like the other recognition studies we
saw earlier except that the questionnaire,
it was in French and it was read aloud by the interviewer who was able to speak
both French and their native dialect in the area.
The interview then read these questions aloud and participants responded,
allowed an interviewer's recorded their responses.
So here essentially what it's asking is to what extent,
um,
sort of what emotion do they see this woman in the photo displaying and have a
series of different emotion terms that they can select from.
And what they found in this study,
um,
with the Burkina Faso people is that they all showed pride,
recognition levels that are above chance,
which you can see down here with the red line.
So they were able just by using a photo,
um,
to,
to pick out that this was a display of pride.
Um,
and so what's interesting here is to think about how universal pride is,
how we all can recognize it.
We all know what function it serves.
We all experienced it and express it at times in which we've achieved something
important.
But if we return to our sort of Kanye west example at the beginning,
um,
you might want to ask,
well it's pride always a good thing for us.
Um,
is it always good to be sort of letting other people know of our accomplishments
and successes?
So we'll be returning to this later when we discuss emotional disorders,
but some people have suggested when studying emotional disorders that too much
pride may actually be manifested in disorders like narcissism or also in the
component of bipolar disorder referred to with mania where there's a overly
enhance sense of self almost to the point of grandiosity.
So although pride can be adaptive for us when we all know it and we recognize it
and it's part of what makes us human,
there can be points in which we have perhaps too much pride.
So we need to sort of kind of carefully keep it in moderation.
Importantly,
also there's findings that suggest that in the case of pride,
in addition to the examples we talked about with narcissism,
that you can see at the bottom that those who experienced too much pride,
especially those that experience it in the absence of sort of adequate merits,
um,
that this can be associated as well with aggressive behavior and antisocial
behavior in addition to narcissism.
Um,
so you want to just be really careful to think about the nature of pride,
what contexts it's experienced in,
in,
and sort of at what level you're displaying it to others.
Okay.
So now that we've talked about pride,
I want to turn to one of my most favorite emotions,
which is the emotion of embarrassment.
Um,
and I think this is a really fun emotion because it's something that we can all
laugh about upon recollection,
recollection,
but sort of in the moment it feels like one of the most painful experiences you
could have,
you almost want to shrivel up and disappear.
And so what I want you to do now,
similar to what we did with pride earlier,
is to engage in a thought exercise with me,
where I want you to spend a couple minutes thinking about a time in your life
that you can remember feeling extremely embarrassed.
So I'm sure we can all think of one of these moments that come to our mind.
So I want you to pick out one for you.
And what I want you to do again is take a pen and piece of paper and write down
some notes about this experience.
So first,
what was the context?
So what was going on when you felt embarrassed?
What happened?
Second,
what sort of feelings to ha,
you know,
went through your mind as you were feeling embarrassed.
What thoughts were running through your mind?
Did you notice any change in your physiology?
Um,
did you notice your heart racing?
Did you notice your cheeks?
Reddening um,
and what kind of behaviors did you engage in when you were feeling embarrassed?
Did you say things to other people?
Did you do particular actions around others when that event happened?
And as a result,
if you were around other people,
how did they react to you?
Um,
when you displayed embarrassment or when you were experiencing it.
So just take a moment and sort of go back to this time you felt embarrassed,
no matter how painful it might be,
and write down some of these experiences.
Um,
I suggest you pause the video now and when you've had a moment to do this,
you can hit play again and we'll go through what scientists discovered about the
nature of embarrassment and see to what extent it sort of matches with your own
personal,
uh,
experience,
um,
or memoir of embarrassment.
So
when we think about the characteristics of embarrassment,
we went through this earlier,
but again,
just as a reminder,
embarrassment is something that is elicited when you sort of violate social
norms or rules.
Um,
as a result,
you often engage in behaviors that are trying to repair relationships.
You're acknowledging that you've remedied or you acknowledged that you made a
mistake and you're trying to remedy or fix that social [inaudible] and others
around you will often respond to you by forgiving.
You may be laughing,
they end actually tend to like you more.
Um,
and they trust you.
Right?
So again,
there's been studies where researchers examined participants' reactions to
various embarrassing situations,
knocking things over or tripping and people find that they like others better
when they display embarrassment in these situations then when they don't.
Um,
and we also find some interesting studies say we're parents will actually punish
their children less if they display embarrassment when they've done certain
behaviors,
you know,
sort of spilling things or behaving inappropriately.
So it's a way that it almost forms a social glue of our,
of our everyday life gives us some leverage to make mistakes.
Okay.
So what does embarrassment look like?
Um,
so embarrassment.
This is something that we really didn't know until quite recently and this is
work that was pioneered by Dacher Keltner at UC Berkeley where he did a
systematic study of people looking embarrassed and found that when he videotaped
people,
um,
who were responding to a loud noise bursts,
where they kind of got shocked and screamed,
they all almost sort of later felt embarrassed about their reaction.
And he took those videos.
And sort of watch them second by second to see what happened,
what did that embarrassment reaction look like?
And here he identified this really sort of elegant sequence of embarrassment
across time.
So he found that the embarrassment sequence kind of goes as follows.
First what you find when people are displaying embarrassment is they sort of
shifted their gaze.
They sort of look away like this after that they show this sort of inhibited
smile.
So they'll look away and sort of almost like bash really smile,
right?
Kind of smiling to the side.
And the smile importantly is non Duchenne.
So this is not an authentic smile.
It's almost sort of a social,
um,
polite smile to others to let them know that you're,
you've done something wrong and you're aware of it.
So you look away,
you smile,
you shift your gaze and you hit tilt your head as he would say,
oh way down into the left.
So you can see some of the sequence here at the gay shift aversion,
that kind of inhibited smile and even tilting your head down into the left.
So these the sweat embarrassing,
it looks like we do this ritual and sometimes we'll even touch our face as we're
looking away down and sort of showing inhibited smile.
Um,
his work did some really interesting research where you can see he actually
looked at these displays of gaze down,
smile control,
a non Duchenne smile.
The shifting of the is tilting the head away.
He actually mapped people across time in seconds.
So you can see one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six seconds,
um,
with his colleague Cameron Anderson to really look at how this really
interesting display unfolds just within a matter of seconds,
right?
So what you wanna do when you see a diagram like this is just to pay careful
attention to the fact that a lot of behaviors are occurring simultaneously and
that many of these behaviors can overlap and time.
So for example,
you can have the gaze aversion continue throughout the entire experience as you
see at the top here.
Now when we think about embarrassment,
the same kind of questions come up for embarrassment as they come up for a pride
that we saw earlier.
And this is the question of,
is this display of embarrassment and universal.
So as you see here in this graph,
researchers presented photos showing this embarrassment display to college
students both in India and in the u s and first they were asked to describe the
display in their own words.
And what you can see here in the graph is that participants reliably identified
a bear snit above chance levels.
So this is the graph here on the left where you see both college students in
India and the u s identify them roughly at the same rate,
around 50%,
which is significantly above chance levels.
Um,
and they also provided similar descriptions of situations that would illicit
embarrassment displays.
Um,
what's interesting though is you see here on the right with his tongue bite
gesture.
So this is a gesture in Southeast Asia that's often also judged as embarrassment
India.
But as you can see here,
not in the u s so that suggests that even though this prototypical display of
embarrassment that we saw earlier is recognized universally across cultures,
that there's also some cultural variation and other kinds of displays that may
signal embarrassment in one country like India,
but not be universally recognized as,
um,
you know,
sort of displaying embarrassment in other cultures like the u s so there's
universal displays,
an embarrassment,
but also potential culture specific displays like the tongue bite,
uh,
in Southeast Asia.
So you might wonder then how do we study or try to trigger embarrassment in the
lab?
So this is something we talked a bit about earlier on in the course,
but I'll remind us when we're trying to study embarrassment as emotion
researchers,
we have to find subtle ways to elicit this emotion.
I'm in an ecologically valid and reliable manner.
So in our lab we've used what's called the karaoke task.
And this was originally developed by Virginia Sturm and Robert Levinson at UC
Berkeley.
And we've adapted in our lab,
um,
to,
uh,
be used as follows.
So participants who will come into the lab,
we'll be told that they're playing a part in a study where we want to people's
physiological reactions to music.
So they come into the lab and they remain seated quietly at baseline.
Then they're told to play along in a karaoke task where we have them sing along
to the Beatle Song,
twist and shout.
Um,
and so they're singing along playing part in this study.
And little do they know,
but later in the study they're actually presented with a video tape of
themselves while they were in the lab singing this karaoke song.
Um,
little did they know that this was going to be a surprise coming up later and at
the end we have them self report their emotion experience.
So I'll show you a brief video of one of my colleagues who came into the lab,
Laurie Santos,
um,
engaging in this task,
singing along to the Beatle song,
twist and shout.
Well shake it again.
Okay,
so that,
come on mom.
Come on.
I'm working on now.
Yeah.
Well
yeah,
no,
you look so good.
Okay.
Yeah,
no,
y'all got a Nah.
Just and I got to know your what
experienced more embarrassment than others.
Um,
and so one of the questions is can you ever experience too much embarrassment?
So we'll return to this question later on in our section on emotional disorders
where we suggest that maybe although embarrassment has these really important
and adapt is social functions that wouldn't experience to an excess,
it can actually play a critical part in disorders such as social anxiety.
So return again to this question of can you have too much of any of the
subconscious emotions like pride or embarrassment for example.
So with this I want to now conclude with our takeaway questions that are focused
on the nature of pride and embarrassment today.
So for today our first question asks,
what are the key features?
So this is the solicitor,
the behavior and the consequence that we talked about today for pride and
embarrassment as a review from our last module.
Second,
what are the key features we discussed today of pride displays?
Sort of what does pride look like?
Um,
and his pride recognized universally both within the United States and cross
culturally.
And if so,
what was the supportive evidence to suggest that was the case?
And then finally,
what are the key features of this sort of elegant and complex sequence of
embarrassment,
display behavior and what is the supportive evidence that would suggest that
embarrassment might be recognized again within the United States and cross
culturally.
We're now going to conclude with an expert interview as part of our experts in
emotion interview series and today for our experts in emotion interview.
Um,
we have the honor of speaking with Dr Dacher Keltner.
I'm a former mentor of mine,
um,
on the nature of embarrassment and what function it serves for the greater good
of humanity.
So doctor Keltner received his phd from Stanford University and completed his
NMH postdoctoral training with Paul Ekman at the University of California San
Francisco.
He's currently a professor of psychology at the University of California,
Berkeley,
as well as the director for the greater good science center that is focused on
translating the theories,
insights,
findings,
and practices of social psychology,
of compassion and cooperation for a broader audience of educators,
policy makers,
healthcare providers,
and just generally interested citizens.
Um,
doctor Keltner is the author of more than 80 scholarly articles and several
books which include books such as born to be good,
the science of a meaningful life,
as well as two textbooks,
one titled Social Psychology and the other focused and co on understanding
emotions.
Um,
he's also authored the compassionate instinct as well.
Doctor Keltner,
not surprisingly,
has received many awards,
including the Templeton positive psychology,
excellence and Research Prize,
outstanding mentor and Teacher Awards from a UC Berkeley and was also named as
one of the 50 visionaries for 2008 by the attorney reader.
So I now turn with special excitement to our experts and emotion interview with
doctor Dacher Keltner.